[Music]
tolkien's ring wraiths are among the
most iconic villains in the lord of the
rings
but although the nazgul's black cloaks
and breathless voices will strike fear
into any fantasy fan not everybody knows
their whole story
this is the whole story behind the ring
race from the lord of the rings
there's a good chance you've heard these
creatures called a number of different
names
and true enough they've got more titles
than you can shake a morgal blade at
sauron's most dreadful servants go by
several different names throughout the
lord of the rings
including among others the nazgul the
ring race the black riders the
nine the fell riders the lyri and the
nine servants
one orc in the return of the king even
refers to them as filthy shriekers
but while the group as a whole are
called many things the names of the
individual ring race themselves have
always been shrouded in mystery the
leader of the nine is commonly referred
to by his titles
the lord of morgul lord of the nazgul
and the witch king are most common but
even he isn't named
the only naz ghoul to ever be directly
named in tolkien's writings is kamul
in the index of unfinished tales tolkien
succinctly describes kamul as second to
the chi
shadow of the east and the black
easterling giving a tiny sliver of
personality to at least one of his ring
rates
unsurprisingly the ring rates are old
almost unspeakably old in fact
by the time of the lord of the rings the
nazgul despite originally being mortal
men
are probably pushing 5 000 years of age
their inception likely dates back to
roughly halfway through the second age
right after sauron created the one ring
each of the nosql receives a ring of
power around this time which unnaturally
extends their lives
over the next few thousand years the
nazi will gradually begin to lose their
physical form
in the fellowship of the ring gandalf
explains to frodo why this happens
saying that a mortal proto who keeps one
of the great rings does not
die but he does not grow or obtain more
life he merely continues
until at last every minute is a
weariness gandalf adds
and if he often uses the ring to make
himself invisible he fades he becomes in
the end invisible permanently and walks
in the twilight under the eye of the
dark power that rules the rings
this is exactly what happened to the
nazgul each of their rings gradually
whittled away their humanity until they
became little more than ghostly slaves
to the whims of the dark lord
their fated existence means that ring
race don't take up much physical space
in the real world
sure they can wear clothes wield weapons
and ride horses but their primary
existence is spiritual in nature
in essence they dwell in an unseen
shadow realm through which they can
dimly interact with the real world
this natural state in which the nazca
will inhabit can often affect the people
who encounter them
for instance when proto puts on the ring
he too enters that spiritual dimension
and is able to see the ring race and all
of their otherworldly horror
when mary and eowyn stab the witch king
in battle both of their arms immediately
go
cold and numb their weapons also
disintegrate with mary's burning like a
piece of wood and aoen's breaking into
splinters
in the fellowship of the ring tolkien
even implies that characters like
gandalf aragorn and glorfendell are
uniquely suited to resist the riders
not because of any physical prowess but
because of the resilience against the
effects of the spiritual realm
with one foot in the physical world and
one on the other side the ring rays end
up using a range of different weapons to
carry out their dirty work
some of these are pretty simple such as
their swords or the witch king's giant
black mace
but the weapons of the nazgul can be far
deadlier and more terrifying in the
novel version of the return of the king
the witch king uses a black dart to kill
theoden's horse
and aragorn later suggests that their
darts can kill much faster than the
average arrow
and then there's the morgle knife that
the witch king uses to stab frodo
on weathertop a notch of the cursed
blade embeds itself into the hobbit's
shoulder while the rest of the weapon
disintegrates
the splinter then begins to warm its way
toward proto's heart
only being stopped by the timely
intervention of elrond's healing
arts if it had struck home though it
would have turned frodo into a wraith
under their command the effect of the
morgle blade is so terrible in fact that
frodo becomes ill on every anniversary
of his stabbing
long after the nosql are destroyed
it's been four years to the day since
weathertop sat
it's never really healed as terrible as
the blades and arrows of the nosql may
be they're nothing compared to the
riders on earthly weapons
while the exact details remain largely
unexplained in tolkien's writings the
ring race wield a number of mind-melting
creator natural weapons that they
regularly employ against their enemies
abject fear is one of those weapons and
the nazgul are able to wield fear to
great effect
striking pure dread into their bows even
from a great distance
in the return of the king during the
siege of gondor the writers fly high
over minas tirith shrieking and
terrifying all below
tolkien writes at length even the stout
hearted would bling themselves to the
ground as the hidden menace passed over
them
or they would stand letting their
weapons fall from nerveless hands while
into their minds a blackness came and
they thought no more of war
but only of hiding and of crawling and
of death then there's the black breath
in the fellowship of the ring mary first
encounters this phenomenon during his
visit to bree when he runs into a nosql
and almost immediately passes out
later during the return of the king the
black breath is connected to a strange
sickness called the black shadow
according to the novel those who are
stricken with it fell slowly into an
ever deeper dream
and then passed the silence and a deadly
cold and so
died so just how did the nazgul come to
be
well their origin lies back in the
second age long before the events of the
lord of the rings
at this time sauron forges the rings of
power including his one ring
after failing to enslave the elves with
his rings the dark lord redistributes
them to the other races of middle earth
nine of course go to the great lords of
men while he never explains who all of
the nine riders are or where
each one comes from in the silmarillion
tolkien reveals that of the nine
three were great lords in the numenorean
race numenor was the incredibly powerful
island nation that frequently came to
blows with sauron during the second age
and it's where aragorn's ancestors hail
from too after they're given their rings
the nine become mighty and are soon
known as great kings sorcerers and
warriors
they're bathed in glory and of course
they also become incredibly rich
as time begins to creep by however they
begin to succumb to the long-term
effects of the rings of power
the nazi will first make an appearance
around the year 2251 of the second age
roughly 600 years after the forging of
the one ring
very little detail is given about their
activity at this time but they likely
spend the next millennium helping sauron
conquer most of middle earth
eventually their greatmaster tussles
with the numenoreans which eventually
leads to the destruction of numenor and
the establishment to the new nations of
arnor and gondor
from there the action picks up again
ending in the war of the last alliance
in which sauron is defeated and the one
ring passes to a seal door
after his defeat at the end of the
second age sauron is left unable to take
on a physical form
this leads to a general peaceful period
in middle earth's history
and as the third age kicks off the naz
will fade into the shadows
over time however the shapeless sour and
once again begins to stir
using his most fearful servants as his
prime movers and shakers
even so it takes some time to get things
going again around a thousand years into
the third age the five wizards first
arrive in middle earth with the express
task of assisting the people of middle
earth and their struggles against sauron
the dark lord himself secretly reappears
around this time too
setting up the stronghold of dogwood and
mirkwood the ring race are almost
certainly around at this point too
for a while the white council even
believes that the evil presence in dog
goldure could be one of the nazgul
of course they couldn't be more wrong a
few hundred years after sauron's
reappearance zanasga will officially
make their return
the witch king then establishes the
kingdom of angmar in the northern
regions of middle earth
while his master slowly rebuilds his
strength the greatest of the nine wages
a centuries-long war with the kingdom of
arnor
eventually the witch king is defeated
but are nor is destroyed in the process
then just six years later the witch king
reappears in the uninhabited wastelands
of mordor and gathers his eight fellow
raids
twenty years later they attack the
gondorian city of minas ethel and
capture it renaming it minas morgol and
making it their home
the nazi will spend the next millennia
preparing mordor for their master's
return
they also slowly chip away at the
strength of his enemies especially
gondor where they kill the king by
luring him into single combat
leaving the stewards to rule the kingdom
until another king should return
many years later the white council
finally attacks dolgodor and drives
sauron out of his stronghold
he then makes his long-awaited return to
mordor where he and the nine prepare for
war
after sauron's return to mordor three of
the ring race are sent back to dogo door
to hold it while their master is away
one of whom is named kamal the
easterling meanwhile a messenger from
mordor arrives at the lonely mountain
in the fellowship of the ring he's
described as a horseman in the night
whose breath came like the hiss of
snakes
clearly suggesting that he was one of
the nazgul this writer brings a message
of friendship from sauron and offers the
dwarves their own rings of power the
dwarves refuse to listen but the
messenger returns more than once hoping
to win them over to the dark lord's side
around this time sauron captures golem
and tortures him into revealing the
location of the one ring
the dark lord then unleashes his nine
riders in the so-called hunt for the
ring
the ring bearer makes a very lucky
escape at this point since the wraith
known as kamal arrives at bagan
just after frodo and his companions have
left
the ring race play a significant role in
the war of the ring
the nine hunt the hobbits on the road to
rivendell and nearly recapture the one
ring on a number of occasions
they later reappear acting as messengers
and generals for sauron and wreak
absolute havoc in the war against gondor
soon enough however the first of the
nine is killed when aoen and mary defeat
the witch king during the battle of the
pelanor fields
later as the armies of the west assault
the black gate of mordor the eight
remaining ring race gather one last time
they're given their final task when
sauron orders them to hurtle towards
mount doom to stop frodo from destroying
the one ring
but they arrive too late in the return
of the king their final moments are
described in fiery detail
tolkien writes the nas ghoul came
shooting like flaming bolts as caught in
the fiery ruin of hill and sky they
crackled withered and went out
and so comes the end of sauron's
greatest servants
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one